comme chaque année de l'animé à la mi
juin
c'est l'heure de la récolte pour l'un
des plus grands exportateurs de litchi
au monde
vietnam une récolte qui ne dure que six
semaines six semaines donc pour écouler
les stocks aux clients vietnamiens mais
surtout aux clients internationaux
problème en raison de la crise
économique liée à la pandémie de
coronavirus les agriculteurs lutte pour
écouler leur production
ils ne voient pas cette année les
acheteurs étrangers venir au marché de
gros pour réaliser leurs transactions en
direct car ils sont bloqués dans leur
pays cette année en raison de la
pandémie on ne voit pas de commerçants
chinois
donc on a surtout vendu à des
commerçants nationaux le prix est donc
très bas le prix augmente normalement
s'il ya des consommateurs étrangers car
ils veulent des litchis de haute qualité
beau et gros pour la consommation
intérieure le prix plus bas et les gens
ne veulent pas que les litchis soit gros
c'est pourquoi le prix national varie
beaucoup
j'espère vraiment que plus de
commerçants arriveront pour consommer
les litchis de l'uqam gagnent
j'espère que les marchandises passent
auront facilement la frontière pour que
les équipes puissent passer sans
problème considéré comme le royaume des
litchis le vietnam exporte
habituellement pas moins de cent mille
tonnes de litchis préparant ses clients
principaux étant la chine l'australie et
les etats-unis ces dernières années le
pis et tourner massivement vers
l'exportation de fruits et légumes
en 2009 ils en ont écoulé pour plus de
trois milliards d'euros mais les
exportateurs vietnamiens de fruits sont
affectés cette année par la flambée des
prix du fret aérien en raison du nombre
limité de vols commerciaux suite à la
crise sanitaire
malgré une demande élevée les
exportations ont diminué de moitié au
cours des deux derniers mois
si les restrictions de déplacements à
l'intérieur du
ils ont été assouplies depuis le début
du mois de mai par le gouvernement
vietnamien
aucune date n'a encore été annoncée
concernant une possible réouverture des
frontières
pour rappel le vietnam est l'un des pays
les moins touchés au monde malgré sa
frontière commune avec la chine il ne
recense à ce jour que 332 cas de
coronavirus et aucun décès